[Música]
georgia vota por dos puestos en el
senado que definiera en el futuro de la
cámara alta estadounidense en una
votación que el mandatario saliente
donald trump apunta como otro referendo
sobre su gestión los resultados de estos
comicios que no se esperan para hoy
decidirán si el presidente electo joe
biden deberá lidiar con una mayoría
opositora en el senado
el chavismo tomó el control de la
asamblea nacional de venezuela tras las
elecciones de diciembre en las que se
impuso sin la participación de la
oposición que considera fraudulentos los
comicios juan guaidó encabezó a la par
otro evento conformado por algunos de
los diputados salientes
los líderes del golfo firmaron un
acuerdo en una cumbre en arabia saudita
la crisis diplomática entre qatar y la
mayoría de sus vecinos del golfo pérsico
que lo acusaban de apoyar al terrorismo
llegaría a su fin después de tres años
de ruptura diplomática
hola cómo están bienvenidos a las
noticias aquí en france 24 mi nombre es
alan austria
empezamos en eeuu avanza la jornada
electoral en georgia donde los
ciudadanos votan por dos puestos en el
senado el resultado de esta segunda
vuelta determinará el control de la
cámara alta y con ello la capacidad de
bloquear o promover la agenda del
presidente electo joe biden ya se han
emitido unos tres millones de sufragios
en la votación anticipada en persona y
por correo es poco probable que se
conozca a los ganadores este mismo día
pues el conteo de votos comenzará hasta
después del cierre de las urnas
más temprano anthony belchí enviado
especial a atlanta nos entregó un
resumen de la jornada lo cierto es que
esos son más de 3 millones de votantes
que ya habían ejercido su derecho al
voto de manera anticipada y
representaban un poco más del 40 por
ciento de todo el electorado del estado
de georgia sin embargo la imagen del
conteo de incesante de votantes en todos
los centros de votación se ha visto en
georgia y es que muchos de estos
votantes decían que eran un
elecciones decisivas y era más
importante que nunca que su bote se
escuchara y no es para menos porque el
estado de georgia va a acabar definiendo
el futuro del senado si los republicanos
revalidan su liderazgo en la cámara alta
muy probablemente la mayoría de las
propuestas y proyectos de ley que se
presenten tanto de la casa blanca como
del congreso acabarán bloqueados por eso
dicen que hay que aquí la gente dice que
su voz se ha de escuchar y por eso han
venido a lo largo de todo el día a
expresar su voz de las urnas
seguimos en eeuu para mañana está
previsto que el congreso certifique los
votos del colegio electoral a la
presidencia normalmente es una mera
formalidad pero este año se va a
convertir en un enfrentamiento acalorado
decenas de los legisladores republicanos
fieles a donald trump están planeando
desafiar estos resultados un movimiento
que desencadenará debates en ambas
cámaras pero que no se espera que anule
la victoria del presidente electo joe
biden
y sólo unos días después de que el nuevo
congreso fuese jurado está previsto que
una sesión explosiva tenga lugar el
miércoles cuando los legisladores voten
para certificar los resultados
electorales de noviembre por lo general
la certificación de los votos del
colegio electoral es un proceso formal
pero decenas de legisladores
republicanos leales a donald trump
planean desafiar la certificación
respaldando los continuos esfuerzos del
presidente para invalidar los resultados
impulsados por afirmaciones no probadas
de fraude electoral en diversos estados
clave las objeciones forzarán debates
tanto en el congreso como en el senado
dividiendo así a los republicanos y
forzándoles a decidir entre mostrar
lealtad a trump o confirmar públicamente
la victoria del presidente electo joe
biden
la maniobra pone al vicepresidente mike
pence uno de los defensores más leales
de tram en una posición especialmente
incómoda como presidente del senado debe
contar los votos de cada estado y
anunciar el resultado haciendo efectiva
la derrota formal de trump pero trump
está presionando le para rechazarla
también
y tengo que decir que confío en que mike
pence esté con nosotros por supuesto si
él no nos apoya ya no me agradará tanto
aún así para que el congreso anule los
resultados ambas cámaras deben votar
para hacerlo con los demócratas
controlando la cámara de representantes-
parece seguro que la propuesta fracasará
cuando yo bailen y yo seamos
juramentados el 20 de enero que lo
seremos block de joe biden será el
próximo presidente de eeuu y yo seré la
próxima vicepresidenta
mientras tanto trampa instado a sus
seguidores a protestar por el conteo del
voto electoral se espera que miles de
personas se manifiesten en washington el
miércoles
hoy se instaló en venezuela el nuevo
parlamento conformado por una gran
mayoría chavista 256 de los doscientos
setenta y siete escaños de la asamblea
estarán ocupados por los partidarios del
presidente nicolás maduro el nuevo líder
parlamentario prometió un diálogo
nacional juan guaidó quien hasta hoy
ostentaba dicho lugar celebró una nueva
sesión por su parte andrés meza muñoz
tiene los detalles
las imágenes de hugo chávez y simón
bolívar entraron escoltadas a la sede
del legislativo en venezuela- un acto
simbólico que representa el regreso del
chavismo a la asamblea nacional la única
institución que no controlaban el nuevo
parlamento se instaló hoy tras las
elecciones del 6 de diciembre en las que
no participó la oposición y en las que
los partidarios de maduro tuvieron 256
de los 277 escaños el nuevo presidente
del legislativo prometió impulsar un
diálogo nacional un diálogo político
donde estemos las 277 y 277 diputadas y
diputados pero donde también estén todos
los factores políticos a ellos también
nos convocaremos a ya ellos si
participan o no participan en este
diálogo nacional por mandato
constitucional la asamblea de mayoría
opositora elegida en 2015 debió terminar
hoy su periodo pero los parlamentarios a
la cabeza de juan guaidó acordaron
extender su mandato un año más hasta que
se celebren nuevas elecciones y aunque
sus decisiones nunca han tenido poder
real desde que el tribunal supremo los
declaró en desacato aún así decidieron
continuar y llevaron a cabo una sesión
virtual
[Aplausos]
hace dos años juan guaidó se proclamó
como presidente interino de venezuela y
recibió el apoyo de unos 50 países
prometió sacar a maduro del poder pero
su tarea se ha complicado a medida que
el líder chavista conserva el apoyo de
los poderes del estado y la fuerza
pública
después de que irán confirmará que ha
intensificado el enriquecimiento de
uranio incumpliendo así el acuerdo
nuclear de 2015 el jefe del organismo
atómico iraní dijo el martes que la
república islámica está en proceso de
instalar mil nuevas centrifugadoras para
ayudar a aumentar la producción la unión
europea dijo que tenía previsto redoblar
esfuerzos para preservar el acuerdo
nuclear y volver a su plena aplicación
por todas las partes
y seguimos con noticias de la región y
es que arabia saudita reabrió sus
fronteras terrestres y aéreas con qatar
tras tres años de crisis política los
estados del golfo son tradicionalmente
cercanos pero a mediados de 2017 arabia
saudita emiratos árabes unidos egipto y
bahrein desencadenaron un boicot acaip a
catar acusándolo de patrocinar grupos
terroristas y de estar precisamente
demasiado cerca de irán enemigo de
arabia saudita veamos este informe de
álvaro o cordero
con un puente aéreo y la apertura de
fronteras arabia saudita puso fin a un
bloqueo de casi tres años a qatar el
príncipe heredero saudita y el emir
catarí cerraron su enfrentamiento con un
abrazo en el aeropuerto de la ciudad de
a lula este acercamiento se produjo en
el marco de la cumbre del consejo de
cooperación del golfo en la que se firmó
la declaración de la ula un pacto de
solidaridad y estabilidad para
fortalecer los lazos entre las naciones
aunque no está claro el contenido del
acuerdo ni las posibles concesiones de
qatar además se hizo un llamado a la
unidad frente al desafío nuclear de irán
hoy necesitamos desesperadamente unir
nuestros esfuerzos para promover nuestra
región y enfrentar los desafíos que nos
rodean especialmente con las amenazas
planteadas por el programa nuclear y los
misiles balísticos del régimen iraní y
sus planes de sabotaje y destrucción
adaptados por sus representantes el
boicot se inició a mediados de 2017
cuando arabia saudita a los eméritos
árabes unidos bahrein y egipto acusaron
a qatar de acercarse a irán un rival
regional en varias guerras como la de
jane wint y qatar también fue acusado de
patrocinar a grupos terroristas algo que
doha negó
los boicots incluso exigieron que qatar
cerrará su canal de televisión
internacional al yazira el avance se
produce cuando joe biden está próxima a
llegar a la casa blanca y es probable
que se acerca irán en un intento por
darle vida a un deteriorado acuerdo
nuclear
la medida de arabia saudita podría ser
un gesto de buena voluntad para
permanecer cerca de la casa blanca
después de que donald trump abandone su
cargo
y finalizamos en eeuu la ceremonia de
entrega de los grammy que estaba
prevista para el 31 de enero se ha
pospuesto debido al aumento de los casos
de coronavirus en los ángeles los
premios más importantes de la música
podrían realizarse en marzo aunque aún
no hay respuesta oficial por parte de la
academia nacional de artes y ciencias de
la grabación responsable de organizar
los graves
así llegamos al final de esta emisión
les agradecemos su compañía sigue en
francés 24
[Música]